uh rescue expert friends of two of those
on board and you're getting some new
yeah you're hearing some news yeah I'm
um
there's a WhatsApp group between
ourselves in the Explorers Club that
we've all been connected to as soon as
this happened and uh our president is uh
directly connected to the the ships that
are out there and the message out there
telling me if you're talking about
debris
it was a landing frame and a rear cover
from the submersible
so again this is a very unconventional
submarine the um
that rear cover is that point the end of
it yeah
and the landing frame is this little
frame that it seems to sit on and that's
how it gets stopped into the landing bit
right so that confirms it's the
submersible